so the first thing I want you to write
is remember when we were doing
simultaneous equations points of
intersection on two different lines the
way that we find where two different
lines intersect is we solve
simultaneously so points of intersection
can be found by solving simultaneously
so ordinarily you don't have to write
this down I just want this as an example
if I gave you a line like this and then
I gave you another line like say how
about this in this case we know three
ways to solve simultaneous equations
which do you think have a look at the
equations which do you think might be
the quickest way because they all work
but which might be the quickest
substitution would regice fine however I
think it might be a bit quicker slightly
quicker and less error-prone see how
there's a minus y 2 plus y you see how
this sort of matched up like I crafted
these equations to match the world if I
add both of these what will happen to
the Y's they will go away our fancy word
of course is they will be eliminated so
we call this solving by elimination so
that's just one method of how many but
my point is once you do that once you
solve simultaneously you'll get an x
value you'll get a Y value and what
those values represent is the points of
intersection okay now here's the thing
again you don't have to draw this but if
you've got a pair of straight lines like
that okay presumably they do intersect
like if they're not parallel
they will only ever intersect once yeah
like it's it's a straight line so it's
not like it could curve back around and
intersect again
okay but what we're about to look at is
when you don't have lines and lines
straight straight lines if you have
lines and curves like the parabolas that
we've been looking at in this topic like
the UM like the we'd oh let's just draw
one in here the widow had per blurs you
might remember from the graphing topic
okay you can see all
now you might get more than one
intersection which is why I put the s in
brackets okay so here's a quick example
that I've written down right these this
pair of equations down these two are
curves that intersect at some points at
least I'm expecting them to okay so what
I want to do is find their points of
intersection the quickest way is to
solve simultaneously in this case in
this case probably by substitution you
see how I have y equals of y equals in
both cases so one of these y equals I
could just swap for say 2x minus 3 okay
so here's how I'm going to do it I'm
going to solve simultaneously I like to
write that down to indicate I'm actually
doing something here which I do have a
meeting over okay
my next line is B that both of these
equations are equal to Y that means both
of these are equal to each other so
let's write that down
x squared minus 3x plus 1 equals 2x
minus 3 they're both equal to Y so they
must both be equal to each other okay
now what you've created is a new
quadratic equation the solutions of this
are your points of intersection let me
say that again in fact I'll even write
it okay the solutions to this equation
the solutions are the points of
intersection okay so once I solve this
that is what I'm going to find it's a
bit of a garbled mess at the moment
everything sort of all shuffled around
what's something I could do that might
make this liter and easier to work with
acne collecting light tones is exactly
what I could do better way than say
simplifying so what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna get all these X's over here
I'm gonna get that 3 I'm gonna add to
both sides so let's see what we get
the x squared terms is not nothing to
collect with that when I subtract 2x
from both sides or does that leave me
with on the Left minus 5x subtracted 2x
what am I going to do with the constants
what will I do
I'll plus I'll add 3 on both sides which
gives me a plus 4 okay now why do I get
them
all over on the left why not for
instance take away one and put it over
there but the answer is we're really
good at dealing with solving quadratic
equations and we have all of them all of
the business on one side okay what can I
do with this we've seen this hundreds of
times before I can complete the square
if I need to what's it what's an easier
option than that fact can I factorize
adds to negative 5 multiply the 4
negative 1 and negative 4 will do the
job ok let's write that down X minus 1 X
minus 4 ok so I successfully factorize
that's nice
so when I get an answer out here this is
why I bothered to write this down
the answer here means something it's 1
or 4 right each x value corresponds with
a Y values I would say x equals 1 means
y equals now let's think about this if
what I've found are the points of
intersection then these values lie on
the straight line and what shapes that
again that's a parabola so it should be
on both so I should be able to take this
number this x value and put it into
either of these equations which do you
think is a better choice probably the
first is just simpler right why watch is
a hard thing where you get to choose a
simple thing so when x equals 1 Y will
equal 2 take away 3 and they do fine so
these two together the X is 1 the Y is
negative 1 that's one of my points of
intersection ok it's not the only one
though right there's the second one when
x equals 4 y is equal to I'm going to go
straight back to that first equation
because it's still the easiest one x
equals 4 so this will be 8 minus 3 which
is 5 so again that that pair of numbers
is a point so it's coordinates are 4
comma 5 those are my points of
intersection ok now if that was the only
question then cool I am done but just
for the sake of it I just want to see
what this looks like
ok
maybe just roughly this doesn't have to
be beautiful don't even bother using a
ruler just draw up a little set of axes
over here okay now what did these
roughly look like I just want a general
sense okay y equals 2x minus 3 is a
steep line sort of like like that okay
if I think about the parabola if I went
and did the work on this or you could
even you can put it to desmos and see
what it looks like you're going to get
something that looks I'm looking it's
gonna look something like this okay so
what am I looking for I'm looking for
where do these two graphs collide where
they intersect okay here's one of the
spots which ones that have a look at the
values we found yeah it's this one right
one to the right one down okay so that's
one negative one and then this guy is
gonna be over here does that make sense
so you can see what you found here
algebraically has a visual meaning oh
look that's where the graphs collide